hello and welcome to the new world
review i'm grand lime waifu and today i
have an obscene amount to talk about so
let's get into it episode 130 had a very
definite curve that i would say we could
categorize as a
downward slope worthy of neon genesis
evangelion we started on the medium high
of the king returning to his castle with
that star wars music of choice and with
everyone who was nearby taking a look at
his flightiness
it was a good look at the ways in which
everyone is taking in the scene and the
knowledge that the only person they
thought was equipped to actually end him
is most certainly dead and most
certainly failed
each side interestingly seems so focused
on the animalistic tendencies of the
other that i'm intrigued fairly
constantly by the differences and
similarities between them both both
sides simply want to exist
both sides believe they are the ultimate
evolution and both sides would probably
if there were enough resources have just
existed it's not like they can't
understand each other and it's not like
they can't understand the needs of the
other and we see that very clearly by
the end of the episode the concept of
human grapes
is kind of gross and i'm not actually
sure why pouf brought it up beyond the
need to stall
i maintain that the king knows exactly
what pouf has been doing and what he
is doing i maintain that poof of all of
them is
actually probably genuinely a villain
the others may lack empathy or the
ability to connect with the others but
perf i'm realizing
doesn't just dislike humans and think
they're filth essentially he also seems
to be misinterpreting his traitorousness
for loyalty on such a consistent level
that i do
in fact wonder whether he's aware that
what he's trying to do is control the
king
more so than wolfy he's inadvertently
becoming the king behind the scenes and
i do wonder if that's a deliberate thing
or not being one with the king
there's a certain power in knowing what
your leader is thinking at all times but
that doesn't mean the king can't read
also what he's thinking it's a two-way
street and i feel like
he's forgetting that his rush to clean
up is somewhat pointless ultimately
because up is also there and knows what
was in the room and who meroem spent the
most time with in that space
it seems odd to me that perf is trying
so hard
to control the memories meroem recovers
in that context
meanwhile what's the name psychic bug
lady palm
yes she has the ability to see what
everyone's up to as long as she doesn't
see new people
as someone who forgets about people's
existence unless i am explicitly
reminded about them
every now and then no matter how i feel
about them i hear you sister
i hear you my brain does that too while
we're talking about her i really like
that she and kilwa have come to some
kind of understanding
i like that they're engaging with each
other in a useful way and i like that
she's sort of been
upgraded to human status which is an odd
thing to say because she's not
human anymore but bear with me when we
first met her she was not human
she was object she was female object who
has emotional issues and we will never
see her interacting with people in a
healthy way because females trademark
can't do that of course she was an
object for nov pretty female of use but
not of interest she was a sex object for
that other [ __ ]
obviously um nah i can't remember what
his name is that that
the the little [ __ ] like that that i
don't even know did he die i don't
remember i don't even remember what
happened to him i'm sure he's around
being a [ __ ] anyway he she was a sex
object for that guy
now she is not controlled being reborn
as she has been she's sort of
safe now from that which is sad because
she had to go through a whole lot of
trauma the only people who never treated
her as an object were gone and killer
and kiwa sees that and essentially calls
attention to it he thanks her out of
need to acknowledge her existence then
calls her a friend and that's that her
object status is gone
now gone and pito on their most awkward
silent angry journey the silence of the
journey the
silence of the situation where they've
gone
the quiet of the remainder of the
episode led to some really interesting
effects
silence has been used to great effect
at times in this series and the
emptiness of that hallway with only the
response to the phone call and the
conversation between pito and poof was
tension building in a way that surprised
me by its outcome what perf has done to
pito is something i'd like to sit with
for a bit perf has
on various occasions mentioned that
people are under his spell
what we haven't had really is any
confirmation that what's happening there
is
actually an ability or just a
verbalization of his ability to
manipulate people
perf's true special ability to me it
doesn't lie in his nen abilities
but in his social skills his control of
people has really been a changer of
events and no one's nan
abilities have had more sway on the
outcome of all of this than perf's
social skills
and regardless of what comes next i
think it's important to note that
perhaps ability to cellular reshape
is if i'm honest the most frustrating
thing that has happened thus far in the
series why
because at this point it feels like
tagashi is using perf as a sort of deus
ex machina i don't call him a mary sue
because he's not good and clearly has
flaws but the abilities he's using have
never been described as having morph
they've never been described as having
changed or developed so we're led to
believe they were always there which
makes me wonder why they were not used
before in other ways i understand that
using one's abilities in new ways
because circumstances have changed is a
thing but unlike up i feel like this new
ability to mimic anyone at all by
changing himself on a cellular structure
is just
i have a problem and didn't really want
to think about how else to solve it
so look perf can do it yay but moving on
because there's a lot to talk about yet
kite
as we suspected he's dead we knew he was
dead he was
already dead we've known he was dead
this whole time and we've known that
gone believed he could fix kite that it
was solvable
it was not i knew that you knew that and
i've been waiting for gone to learn it
since we saw that head in pito's lap
so what to say about this sequence
pito's hatred of gone was undermined by
its respect of gone
or its hatred of gone was bolstered by
its respect of gone
and i'm not sure which it was gone could
not
and so did not hear everything pito said
something pito said was of great
interest to me but i have no idea if it
was deliberate and i don't know if the
translation is right
i'm hoping that it is because i'm
fascinated by it when pito spoke of
being able to bring people back to life
it used the past tense it said i was
unable to bring people back what that
suggests to me is that pito now
at this time is capable of it and has
made a choice not to
this more than anything at all
illuminates the state of affairs for me
it shows the shift in status more than
anything else
gone spiral into hopelessness his spiral
into helplessness
all of that can be remedied by a
realization that pito is the one to
blame
as his thoughts want to assert but that
he didn't respond to that tells me he's
full of something else and distracted
and
potentially fatally though i doubt it
maybe i'm wrong probably am i just don't
know
pito remembering gone asking his name
not looking at him
the rebuilding of pito as gone faded was
a
hootiful use of energy in an otherwise
static scene
because we really didn't need to see
kite's eulogy again but gone did it's
incredibly rare that we see into gon's
mind and the fallout of that the last
time we did was when kite's body fought
him
at that time he filled with rage for
getting tight because there was someone
to blame and
hate and kill for what had been done now
gone has no one to blame but himself the
power of this character has been in his
unwavering belief that he could fix
anything and this is proof that he can't
and it's fascinating to watch because he
grieves in real time but it's hard to
know what he's grieving
is it kite is it the closest thing he
knew to his father is it his own
strength is it himself is it his father
is he grieving because kite told him not
to harm animals and he somehow managed
to ignore that teaching
if gone was stoned for the last 10
episodes or so now he's paper
and pitot is repairing their scissors
the gone is shifting between two fair
assumptions is interesting they're two
views that are both actually accurate
you know if he hadn't gone along with
kite kite would likely have survived
because he wouldn't have had to consider
protecting the boys who he had actively
told he wouldn't protect
arguably in that way kite killed kite
he sacrificed himself it's neither of
these two characters fault because kite
is
was unfortunately was a grown-up capable
of making his own decisions
it really should have been on him to
tell gon the child not to get involved
in the situation
it wouldn't have worked but that is the
thing people keep forgetting kite has
been
so frequently dehumanized in this arc
that it bears mentioning that
kite has been as symbolic as palm more
so really because
he's been dead in this arc more than
he's been alive and was the inciting
incident but so
forgettable we keep getting shown images
of his basic existence
in a number of ways we see how simple
the character is but when we see those
basic insignificant behaviors we're also
looking from
gone's point of view and we see both
that gone has
over signified the existence of someone
he knew for a few days and
deified that existence such that the
question of whether kite was strong
enough to resist pito's original
abilities was
unarguable to him regardless the two
halves of gone become
fixated on whether to blame himself or
something else technically described he
began to question
internal or external locus of control
and this is a review
right so i use these technical terms
because i'm literally writing my
doctorate about them
the internal argument at play is asking
whether he killed kite or if pito killed
kite
someone with an internal locus of
control or a belief in their own ability
to influence
outcomes would say gondid gone could
have done something better to influence
the outcome and so it is gone's fault
that kite was killed in his body defiled
on the other hand someone with an
external locus of control might believe
that forces outside gone controlled the
outcome
in this case it's fair to say that pito
killed him and that's a deeply
fascinating concept to me because it
touches on so many individual areas of
my own scientific interest
but i will hold myself back from
wandering into philosophy mode because
we'll never get out of it
simply put being able to sit somewhere
in the middle or look at the situation
from the view of both and find a
balanced outcome in which you can
actually accept
that it was both is a mark of balance
it's a mark of maturity
but gone's a kid so that level of
insight is an interesting one
especially in a child who has questioned
and seen the world so often
in black and white of course he'd think
only one of these things can be true
that said if gone comes to the
conclusion that it's both in his current
state i could imagine him
trying to punish both in some way
depending on whether or not pito
actually responds to him and how they
decide to react to things
so i'm excited to know what comes next
because it's rare that research actually
goes into that behavior its outcomes and
it's kind of fun it's fun for me now
this is this is like actively fun
because it's touching on the things i'm
i'm directly
directly interested in this isn't how i
usually do things but this episode
touched on some really
really interesting things that i needed
to go into on a deeper level so
for this week that's it from me if you
enjoyed this random drop into my
research and want to hear my thoughts on
the next episode
click here here and here i mean i have
the next episode will be next next week
i don't know hit the bell spread the
word and i'll see you
next time